[Music]
why what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are talking about a
subject that we have yet to talk about
on the show today we're gonna be talking
about enthusiastic consent culture
creating a fun and safe and sexy
environment for us all we are sitting
down with Aurora Quinn Elmore thank you
for joining us on the show
thanks for having me we really
appreciate it absolutely and your
background in psychology and cognitive
science and managing director of clear
thinking which I've used and I really
like I like the project a lot yeah
definitely definitely makes us look in
the mirror and be like do I really make
decisions that way and then now this new
project that you're working on do yes to
consent culture so absolutely I teach us
a bit about this because this is this is
at a time that's really important for
humanity to be figuring this out
absolutely yeah yeah so my day job is
the managing director of clear-thinking
org and this new side project that I'm
that I'm launching called enthusiastic
consent culture is something that has
been an area of activism and work in the
way that and one primary way that I've
been able to serve my community in the
last couple years and it's been kind of
crystallized most recently as something
that I'd like to be able to create more
materials and resources around so that
it's not just me and my energy and my
and my time going into it to solve
individual situations I want to be able
to create materials that allows the best
practices that I've found to kind of be
scaled up to be to be used in Burning
Man camps in festivals in community
spaces in you know any anywhere anywhere
where the organizers want to have a fun
and safe and sexy environment where
people can feel comfortable can feel
free and can feel good about the
interactions that they
have like oh you're immediately jumping
to how to scale this yeah with resources
absolutely that's huge
yeah now you're gonna structure this out
and figure out how to do this well and
that was actually something that I've
been struggling with a bit in the last
six months because I've realized that
this feels like something that I am more
able and willing to do than many are
willing to sort of step into these
difficult situations where harm has been
done perhaps someone has been causing
harm in the same kind of way for years
and years you often see this as pattern
of patterns of bad behavior where
perhaps someone's people try to step in
people try to try to influence it but
it's it's it's hard for people to kind
of get enough certainty in order to take
take definitive action in order to
prevent someone from continuing to cause
harm in a given community so I found
that I was more able and more willing to
take on those cases to sort of talk with
the people involved try to get a sense
particularly I'm I've found it
particularly interesting to talk to
offenders to talk to people who are not
doing a good job of getting consent for
sexual contact and understand what's
going wrong in their minds that's
causing this problem you know it
requires a whole degree of vulnerability
for them to be like I'm not doing this
the best possible way I want to talk to
you I want to learn how to become better
yeah yeah and then also the bravery on
the other side as well to approach and
say that something has happened and I
want to talk about I want to figure it
out and yeah yeah or just say no and be
very you know brave and clear about that
as well is this all very nuanced human
communication yeah yeah yeah one just
briefly briefly circling back so I had I
I was noticing that this was a strength
for me but I was frustrated at the the
ways in which it didn't feel scalable
and then it was just in the last week or
two that I've been starting to think
about how I might be able to build
materials write blog posts perhaps do
some videos that might be able to scale
this and allow others to take what I've
done and run with
so this is a very early stage for the
project for me but I'm excited to see
where it goes you are attempting what
many people are very scared to talk even
talk about it's true yeah
and that's huge where you knew you're
the black sheep that's awesome it's
really important to be the black sheep
would be the point zero zero one percent
that's willing to put themselves forth
and be like let's figure this out
because it's more it's very complicated
yeah
okay so then there's a you know there's
been a process for you of coming to this
moment yeah so now that process tell us
about that and now you're at this moment
like what are these stories and
anecdotes that have led you to to
feeling the way you feel now yeah sure
sure
so there's there's a couple different
places I could start but I think the the
more the most recent inspiration from
this project probably came out of this
event called ephemeral which is this
delightful festival out on the water
it's on the Sacramento Delta near
Stockton and it started as sort of a
libertarian seasteading experiment with
the the ideas that there's many people
including libertarians who are
interested in experimenting with
governance yes but it turns out that all
the land is already taken and fighting a
war for land is rather expensive so
however expensive it seems to set up
platforms to live in the ocean in
international waters that's a lot
cheaper than fighting someone for land
so if you want to experiment with
governance that's sort of one viable
option so so many other benefits to like
being right there in the marine
ecosystem there's no light pollution you
look at the stars all the time
yeah there's and there's so many
interesting designs that people have
proposed for building homes in
international waters yeah beautiful
stuff oh absolutely yeah yes so I think
nine years ago if Emeril started as sort
of like a very small-scale experiment
with this like what would it be like for
us to sort of go out and get some house
boats build some platforms
just be out on the Delta for a week so
very very small scale but we're all
about sort of Minimum Viable products
here in Silicon Valley and so over time
it has evolved - it still has it still
has a libertarian strain in in some
cases but it's this funny mix of
cultures that's something that's I find
particularly interesting about ephemeral
you have sort of the hippie burner types
from San Francisco you have the
libertarian political types you have
sort of the techno activists you have
people who are doing interesting things
with cryptocurrency and you also have
this mix of like sailors and local Delta
folks who all who all sort of come
together so it's this delightful
wonderful clash of cultures but one
thing that had come up around that is
that I think a lot of people are coming
in with different expectations
so there's sort of the hippie Berners
who are you know jumping in the Delta
naked and wearing all their beautiful
skimpy costumes which i think is a
wonder wonderful fun but I think that's
often surprising or unnerving to people
that aren't aren't used to that and I
think that Burning Man culture has sort
of I'm sure it has its own challenges
but at least in the Bay Area I feel like
enthusiastic consent which is the idea
of if I'm if I'm interacting with
someone sexually I want to make sure
that I have not just they're a reluctant
consent or technically they said yes but
I want to know that it's like a [ __ ] yes
it's a state [ __ ] yes enthusiastic yes
yeah yeah we even say that about
business all the time so your intuition
tells you it's either a [ __ ] yeah or a
no I mean I think it's a good rule for
life in general to have you know in
enthusiastic [ __ ] yes for whatever
you're doing and so so basically one of
the one of the challenges that I think
has always been an issue with ephemeral
is that there's a higher level of sexual
harassment than you see it kind of other
festival events that I've gone to at
least where it's more specifically
sorting for a sort of liberal
progressive
San Francisco burner types that are
probably more familiar with the culture
of sort of fully opt-in I think we have
I think we have a culture that sort of
teaches it is it is strong and masculine
to sort of push for what you want and
take what you want and I think we're
we're beginning to see a change in
culture around that but you have the
iconic scene for me is from Star Wars
where I think Leia is working on fixing
something the ship and then Han Solo
comes in and I don't remember exactly
how the interaction goes but it it but
he's trying to kiss her and she doesn't
want to be kissed and I think at some
point he like pushes her up against the
wall and kisses her anyways and you're
thinking about this and it's like a
metal box in the middle of space he's
the captain
so it's this but it's this romantic
moment in the film is him overcoming her
resistance so I think we're in a culture
that sort of teaches us that it is right
for women to resist even if they want it
and it's right for men to push through
to get what they want right so that like
sets people level for all their shows
all of this all of this so like honestly
given the given the culture that we've
been raised hard to get things exactly
right right because I think there's a
narrative that if women don't play
hard-to-get then they're a [ __ ] and if
men don't push for it they're not a man
and they'll never get it because they're
purposely doing hard to get things right
right so I think we're absolutely set up
for failure mention the in these
contexts and a lot of women for
especially for the ones that really want
to see if the guy wants to actually be
with them well want to see how hard the
guy will work to berate them yeah -
that's interest yeah I think there's I
think there's there's this funny set of
games that people are playing that sort
of set one up for a lot of damage
because it's you know it's depending on
one's level of social intelligence like
I don't I don't exactly know how one
would tell the difference between a
woman playing hard-to-get and a woman
who's not interested like maybe some
guys do but I don't know how to tell
that there's a lot of nuance right there
that one's yeah yeah yeah so if there
even is that like that tiny little micro
expression
the end of what they say they might look
at you just like you know a little bit
of this right at the end of when they
say you know no I don't want it you know
or whatever and then I and then you how
can you use social intelligence I it's
easy for me to tell when ha they're not
interested the difference between
playing hard-to-get and down if it's
binary like that I'm great I'm glad to
know for some people it's easier for
them to tell I think the the challenge
that I've that I've seen again and again
particularly when I'm speaking with men
who have a pattern of violating the
consent of the people that they're with
is that they think the person that
they're with is opting into it or would
leave if they weren't opting into it and
the you know I can I I can I can get I
can get more into that into that back
and forth but I wanted to circle back to
the ephemeral origin story first effect
yes and then we'll come back to the back
to the signals yeah yeah so anyways so
ephemeral delightful event had this
problem of a higher level of sexual
harassment and and of course the the
organizers wanted a safe and delightful
and sexy environment they they didn't
want this but i I've been attending
ephemeral for five years I've been
helping with the build week for four
years which is this wonderful wonderful
experience of a couple dozen people out
there like learning how to use power
tools got to learn how to use an impact
driver that was amazing but so four
years ago after my first build I had
these amazing experiences of connection
and friendship but I left really [ __ ]
angry because of the amount of sexual
harassment I had experienced at a
femoral that I had worked so hard to
create this event and then I wasn't I
didn't feel like people were respecting
my autonomy over my own body like
basically that and so the there's been
various efforts by the organizers and
kind of what's the word bring people
into the culture of enthusiastic consent
and make sure it was understood what was
expected and so that was four years ago
three years ago there was a very
in-depth process where it was like 30
minutes sit-down kind of grill you make
the person read the thing we called it
immigration like all of these things
kind of rug people along the wrong way I
suppose and then two years ago I was
there for the for the build and kind of
fell into the role of welcoming people
and figuring out a script that worked
that we could get through in like five
or ten minutes that felt more of a
joyous hey welcome here's how we do
things here if you want to join us this
is how you can do things here here's how
you can check like one of one of the
things that I really like it's not at
the level of sexual connection but it's
just like offering a hug rather than
going in for a bear hug what before the
person can respond because there's
there's sort of the there's the kind of
gross feeling of like a guy going in for
a hug before you before you can respond
and then like having a grope as part of
that it's just not fun right that
horrified look but so that's just like
one way of like casually building in
enthusiastic consent to everyone's
interactions on a day to day basis so
that was two years ago where I recruited
some volunteers and worked more on the
script just sort of verbally and then
this year I had a bit more time to plan
and I put together sort of the bullet
points for people to go over including
like the the the sort of warnings that
people can look for if they're if
they're trying to if they're trying to
figure out whether or not the person
that they're with is into what they're
doing some warning signs that they might
not be in that they might be struggling
to communicate that clearly but an
important component of this also is we
sort of asked we asked everyone if
you're if you're not enthusiastic about
an interaction please try to communicate
that clearly to help the other person
not upset you or harm you and then the
other direction is like if someone says
they don't want to do a thing that
you're excited to do please try to take
that gracefully because
the critical information for you to have
in order to not harm them so it's just
trying to make it make it easier and
gracefully more graceful to ask for what
you want and you know is an answer and
give no as an answer so this is this
slow process over four years or so of
you being at a femoral and going through
like iterations of how to best approach
this subject as people board as like an
immigration well we're trying not to use
the immigration language now cuz that'd
piss people off we called it welcoming
welcoming okay yeah and to be totally
clear the the the so Elysium was one of
the islands that have memorized I not
have a welcome to Lollapalooza or
Bonnaroo or whatever music festival and
it's like hey like respect enthusiastic
consent that's what I'm interested in
they get [ __ ] yeah yeah absolutely and I
just want to be totally clear that the
the leadership at ephemeral and Elysium
which is the island that I was on was
like a hundred percent they they wanted
this problem solved they they care very
much about this at least ur talking
about it and they're moving to her
solution yeah exactly but I was I was
personally really pleased that this was
something that I think is a strength of
mine so I was really glad that this was
something that I could take on so that
they could focus on all of the things
that are you know their areas of
strength like building amazing things
and creating a safe environment and all
of that so yeah this felt like a good
way that I could contribute to it and my
work and that kind of inspired me to
make a larger project and share those
materials and then now it's kind of on
the way of these materials are
developing and now it's like how do we
take them to more festivals and events
and that kind of stuff a friend actually
just reached out to me today asking if
there were materials that I could share
with him that his girlfriend's Burning
Man camp could use and that was before I
even announced that I was working this I
don't even reached out but that great
yeah yeah and even just that little tiny
touch point you know a material can be
even your medium blog post talking about
kind of like a couple important
principles it can be a digital PDF that
you send yeah it's really relatable okay
yeah like this is [ __ ] yeah this is No
yeah
yeah and and and be careful with the
nuance the heart to get the push through
the barrier thing in the middle that's
okay so now there's this there's like
art should we go into the to the nuance
into that gray area now though and then
like how like how difficult it is I
guess for then you know someone to that
it was an aggressor to come forth and be
like hey like I feel like I'm not doing
it right or that someone that was a
victim in that case was this to come
forth and say that hey I want to talk as
well so this is a how you deal with
those situations and we can do better
yeah yeah yeah sure so I think I want
one framing that I've found helpful is
that it's the responsibility of the
initiator escalator to get enthusiastic
consent from their partner I don't
necessarily know that it's important to
have a verbal yes for everything like
can I touch your thigh can I touch your
shoulder can I like that at a certain
point at a certain point like you can
you can you can read some some signals
but it's like also the responsibility of
the person who's escalating to know like
am i someone that like actually has a
big problem reading signals and tends to
have like a problem with wishful
thinking maybe I just need to be really
explicit or other people who are like
you know I'm pretty solid on this all
I'll check before I like do major jumps
in escalation of like sexual contact but
I know well enough to to read someone
signals to see like the other into me
yeah they're interested in in you know
escalating this but just sort of
checking in at a couple at a couple
important checkpoints like you know
perhaps before you take someone's
clothes off or before you escalate to
different sexual acts they just sort of
knowing like what the so I think there's
there's some subtlety there and I
definitely want to respect people's
Styles around that and knowledge of
themselves yeah but yeah the the gray
area stuff I think is really interesting
because that's where I find the most
trouble particularly in our communities
and the a term I had heard I heard
recently which was kind of new for me
was dead fishing so it's a tactic that
some people often women but I'm sure men
use it also is if they're in a sexual
situation that they are uncomfortable
with or don't want to continue they'll
often like kind of go limp and stop
interacting that can often be like a
trauma response if people have histories
of abuse or assault or it can just be
like this is awkward and I don't want it
to happen but I also like don't want to
make the person mad or upset them so
some some tips that I that we included
in the in the in the sort of intro
welcome to a femoral here's the bullet
points was that some signals to look out
for that someone might be uncomfortable
as if they stopped reciprocating trust
or sorry if they stopped reciprocating
touch or if they're avoiding eye contact
or if they're failing to respond to like
a verbal ask or is this okay does this
feel good do you want me to keep doing
this so if they're not responding if
they're not responsive that's often a
sign of discomfort so and the the advice
at that point is just like stop what
you're doing and wait until you have
clarity so quite a term right
[Applause]
sure yeah yeah and to be to be clear I I
think it's really important if people
are not comfortable with the situation
that they're in that they sort of speak
up and communicate that more clearly but
not everyone feels able to do that and I
think there's it's important for people
to know that someone that they're
interacting with sexually might have a
trauma history or other things that get
in the way of them being able to do that
but I think if if someone as an
individual notices wow I'm really not
good at communicating when I'm in a
sexual situation that I'm not
comfortable with it I think it's useful
and valuable for that person to think
about like what work can I do with my
therapist or with my friends in order to
like play through scenarios to get
comfortable speaking up for myself like
what work can I do to get better at
helping someone avoid wrong because that
that might be how you are right now but
I don't think that's how you have to be
forever I think there's room for growth
in practice around that totally and that
that's another thing that I've been sort
of looking at recently related to this
is sort of the concept of practicing
being brave and so I think that excuse
me I think that that comes up in a lot
of areas around this practicing being
brave asking for what you want and
saying what you don't want and if
someone if someone violates your
boundaries or fails to get consent
practicing being brave by bringing that
up to them and making sure they know
what happened why it wasn't okay and
something something that I've been doing
recently is when I have conversations
with people who have a pattern of
violating consent it's really important
for me that they get the learning they
need to get that they were missing that
caused them to do harm and then I
usually ask them like what's going to
change in your behavior that you're not
going to keep causing harm in this way
asking them to describe to me what
changes they're gonna make yeah exactly
they have to recite back to you
we sounding good Ron great well it
doesn't have to necessarily be anything
I suggest it just has to for myself I've
started to kind of play a role in my
communities where I try to there's been
one situation in the past where there
was someone who had a pattern of this
behavior and based on my conversations
with him I was not confident that he was
going to shift his behavior so I yeah so
we specifically have disinvited him from
coming to our co-living houses and
worked with the leaders of another
number of other communities to
communicate like based on what we know
we don't think this is safe person to
have around it doesn't seem like he's
adjusting his behavior in a way that's
that's needed and so that's that
sometimes the outcome but I for me it's
very important to kind of take a
restorative justice approach and at the
very least try to do what I can to help
the person learn to stop causing damage
so it's the looking in the mirror
objectively and having others also
helped with that process yeah yeah and
damn there's so much gray area it's nuts
I mean I hear you on that but I don't
think there needs to be like I I
honestly don't think it needs to be that
complicated the party hour no yeah yeah
like it like the parties need to help
move to a [ __ ] you out or a no and make
it really clear which one it
yeah and I think in some cases people
parties will want to have a sexual
experience together
but but there's no fun in just like you
know taking all your clothes on both of
you and just going and there's no fun
and just being like no and then
believing you know so there's like so
then a lot of the funds in the middle
too and that's where a lot of the gray
is maybe yeah I I think that uh I think
that there's room for gentleness and
innocence and kind of biotin as' in the
escalation while it's still kind of
clear I think there can be that's where
a lot of like Pat that's where a lot of
those most I think beautiful human
interactions are in that kind of
gentleness that gentle touch that those
gentle eye contacts those you know you
can sense and feel when somebody else is
really excited to participate in some
play right and that's that's amazing
those are some beautiful feelings and it
requires a high level of social
intelligence to do that yeah yeah how do
you train that objectively like you were
saying somebody can go through the
process of hearing it and then not
wanting to be like no I don't want to
change like this yeah yeah well I mean I
think that one one outcome that might
come out of this is that both parties
might want to have sex but perhaps one
party is like not good enough at
expressing what they want and sort of we
used to perhaps used to the guy pushing
through resistance and then they won't
get laid like I think that's an OK
outcome that in some cases people don't
get laid because they're not able to ask
for what they want and I think it's
important for people to be okay with the
idea like I think they want it but I
can't get a straight answer from them so
I'm just not going to get laid like I I
hope I hope that people have have as
much fun as they can but I think it's
honestly I think if if if if someone's
not able to express what they want I
hope that the consequences for them are
they don't get laid when they want to
get laid I'm just like that's a much
better outcome
someone has has sex that they don't want
to have so like I'm way better I'm Way
happier with the with the outcome of
like yeah like I'm all for people having
a ton of great sex but you know if we're
gonna if we're gonna over correct in one
direction I'd prefer to be in that
direction I was just imagining
civilizations orbiting other stars that
don't even have to worry about sex for
reproduction yeah how does how does that
work
we have no idea it's just an interest in
the imagination thing but there well I
mean there are well with some on earth
that we're a species that has sex beyond
the need to procreate so it's it's that
that human connectivity that that it's
it's a it's important don't other
intelligent animals also choose to have
sex for fun the bonobo monkey
I think are the only wham I don't know
who I had a not aware of dolphins Wow
yeah I wonder if yes let's end this mock
they deserve respect and I sound get
back to this joke okay so now okay so
now we've I think we've kind of made it
I like how the resource is if the
resource is very visually stimulating
like here's a spectrum there's the no
and then there's the [ __ ] yeah and then
there's all this nuanced gray area in
between like have fun but also be very
clear with with what what your direction
is are you in the yes are you in the no
hey you know be clear so you kind of
want to like what would that shape you'd
be like a funnel I guess in some way
you've got to pick a side you know on
your way down yes or no as you're
playing and make that clear to the other
person and then like just I love
imagining things visually like this and
I love the idea of getting like a little
like like a little image text when I
enter a festival and it's like hey this
is our like you know fun like consent
enthusiastic consent like and I just get
a reminder and I'm like yeah like that
little reminder helps
as I walk into be like remember right
right yeah I'll have to think about what
the what the visuals are we gonna do one
thing I'm really interested in doing
around this is that in my in my work at
clear thinking we don't we do a ton of
quantitative research when we're
building new tools so I'm really
interested in doing some quantitative
research around this using similar
methods so you just use Mechanical Turk
to get like a large sample size pretty
quickly it's demographically it's pretty
representative of the US and Mechanical
Turk Mechanical Turk yeah and what's
that again oh it's just where you can
it's I think it got bought by Amazon but
you can basically just pay people to do
small tasks so in our case we pay people
to take surveys or answer questions and
so that's a way that we can quickly
gauge both the effects of our tools so
we'll often do like a experimental group
in a control group of a sufficiently
large sample to be sure to be you know
confident that our tool is having the
outcome that we want it to have so we we
have where we're running at some
research right now and like habit
formation and other research around goal
achievement so there's a bunch of
different techniques these are huge yeah
absolutely absolutely
probably the one of the two of the most
important things almost absolutely goals
yeah yeah yeah well and so there's a
bunch of techniques from academia that
we know has some effect size and we're
interested in kind of putting those
head-to-head to figure out like what's
the most useful tool in the real world
that will actually work for people
because that's often like the gap that
you get from academia where they kind of
establish that it works and perhaps it's
popularized in a book but we really just
want a tool that's on the tip of
people's on people's fingertips that
they can sort of use and implement but
yeah so circling back I'm really
interested in doing some quantitative
research around this to get a like
particularly the questions I was
interested in asking was for for any
given participant find out their age and
gender and some other basic demographic
information and then ask each person
when you're with someone and interested
in escalating a interaction
towards sex what are the what are the
signals you give in order to express
that interest and then similarly if
you're with someone and you got the
sense that they want to escalate things
sexually and you don't want to what are
the signals that you give to try to
communicate that and then the flipside
of that would be what signals do you
look from the other person that they're
enthusiastic about it or what signals do
you look for that they don't want it
know what I'm predicting is that there's
going to be some misalignment between
what signals people give verse look for
that might be like a lot of the cause of
harm but I'm just really excited to get
like like I have from the qualitative
perspective I have some some Inklings of
that but I'm really curious to back it
up with data and see what see what comes
out of that I want this that is really
good I like that yeah yeah that's really
good I think compliments is probably one
of them hmm I agree yeah thank you
compliments I contact icon lots of
laughing and the casual touch on the
shoulders yeah yeah yeah touch on the
side really good yeah touch on the side
that's okay
he's it's an interesting point because
for one of the things that like pissed
me off the four years ago at FM our
aisle was like random guy that I didn't
really know and didn't have any energy
with kept like touching me on the side
and often if I was like in a bathing
suit top and it's like I don't want your
hand on my side like there's no energy
there but a cook but you know I think
it's I think it's something where it's
not always necessary to have verbal
consent for everything but that would be
something where I would hope he would
have the wisdom to know that like that's
not something I do to a random woman
that's something that perhaps I do to
someone who I'm building energy with so
I think it's all subtle it's all it's
all like there's a lot of taste and a
lot of preferences involved that are
complicated and it's hard to know what
people are gonna like but I think
there's sort of trade-offs between like
what's the harm done if I'm wrong in the
way I read this verse like
so it's like the the need for the need
for like clearer and more verbal consent
I think increases as the harm of
McKesson wrong increases yeah when I was
in fifth grade I my first girlfriend she
took me behind her house and she just
looked at me and she said kiss me yeah
and that was you know I waited I just
wanted to let you know I loved I just I
just want to let throw that out there
for anyone ever giving me a hard time
about being too aggressive or you know I
I just waited for her consent
oh her enthusiastic consent that sounds
enthusiastic yeah I love receiving
enthusiastic consent good yeah when they
start kissing that's when you're 11
years old it's it just seems it just
seems so much more fun looking back at
it at 11 - that's another thing you know
of course you know just the innocence of
that and who we were at the time and ooh
you brought this up it's the a lot of
that is that stereotype of sluttiness if
only we kind of dtap food that crap well
though she told me to do was kiss her
you know it was a kiss this kiss thing
in general there's so much taboo around
and if and if there wasn't that then
there would be I think more of an
approach from women potentially to enter
into a enthusiastic and that would be
easier for the gray area to be less gray
yeah yeah honey and I think that I
definitely see that in in my communities
that women feel more comfortable owning
their desire and owning their sexuality
and owning their boundaries so yeah so
there's a there's a couple things that I
want to touch on as we you know as we
come to yeah 15 minutes yeah perfect
okay
you just can't get our noise there's our
15-minute timer all right so on our way
out when you were when we were hanging
out for the first time it was at them it
was after we produced a Michael Pollan
event and then we were at the hanging
out at the after party at symmetry labs
shout out to Alex green who we just had
on the show a couple weeks ago actually
yeah
symmetry labs beautiful audio-visual art
hanging out at their place you and I
cross paths and I immediately noticed
that you articulating yourself in ways
that I found very interesting and so
then we had to even take our
conversation from standing to sitting
and like away from all the noise so that
we could really dive deep and we dope
deep for like an hour it was it was a
good conversation okay so as as we were
having this conversation
I remember we started talking about our
both of our interest in the in in what
is in how we evolved how humanity
evolved and if humanity evolved in
different ways what would have it been
like and I remember we were talking
about simulations and okay if you can
run a simulation like what we have
there's a little bit of a there's quite
a patriarchy now what if you could run a
simulation where it became a matriarchy
you know what would really great
matriarchy things be what would be like
the not-so-great news iake things be and
like how could you take the good
patriarchy things and the good
matriarchy things and mess that miss
them together and I remember we were
just having that conversation I thought
that was really awesome and also your
definition of feminism women are people
and should be treated as I was like I
was like how can somebody not agree with
that right yeah yeah I mean and there's
there's there's there's more to it but
that that sort of seems like the most
basic and important version of it that I
think is to me at least that's the right
way to start the conversation because I
think you can kind of find points of
agreement and build from there that's as
a side note I'm actually I'm fascinated
by the idea of public policy evolving
according to like
what can 80% of the population agree on
make that public policy and then like
shift your shift your alliances each
time so doesn't have to be the same 80
percent but just sort of like focusing
focusing policy on the things we can
agree on not the things that we disagree
on but I don't know how you do that
mechanistically in a voting system but
but yeah I think broadly speaking in my
in Silicon Valley and in my communities
it's beautiful to see so many brilliant
talented carrying women stepping into
positions of more authority more
influence and more being able to
contribute their full talents to their
community to the world to the
professional world because I think that
that's that's one of the tragedies of
history is the way in which we have
failed to benefit from all the talents
of the of the world so that's that's
women that's people of color that's
queer people that's any of the others
that were prevented from expressing
their full talents and sharing their
full talents so I'm excited excited to
see how that how the balance is directed
and this is what we asked so much on the
show about how do we maximize human
potential and this has a lot to do with
women people of color and that's people
calling the US when you look at you know
white people in other places in the
world there are oppression systems white
people in other places in the world
because they're also treated and equally
in those places so it's like how do you
maximize their potential or how do you
maximize the potential of you know just
like how do you get equality of
opportunity to people how do you get
equality of opportunity to kids and you
talk about that a lot so yeah yeah and I
think for myself at least another
baseline another component of that is
wanting like I think we we as humanity
have the resources and capabilities of
right raising the baseline of the human
experience there is no reason why any
humans shouldn't have healthy food clean
water safe place to sleep at night the
ability to raise their kids well have
educate themselves and educate their
children like we can afford to do that
if we were to prioritize that as as
humanity we could get that done and you
know I think that that's a that's a
separate component that's a separate
component from the equality of
opportunity I think we can just afford
to raise the baseline so yeah that's
interesting because to me I used to kind
of call them the same raise the baseline
quality of opportunity they kind of seen
this food water energy education these
sort of baselines this yeah okay so all
right how about we ask you these you
know a couple questions on the way out
I'm super excited for this day yeah yeah
practicing being brave is one thing I
want to cover really quick just a more
of a deep dive so a brief deep dive a
problem okay yeah it's just I'm thinking
about throwing an event and then
probably also building out some
resources for this because an
observation that I've made in this work
is that there's people aren't practiced
at being brave they're not practiced at
when someone confronts them and tells
them about something that they did was
harmful people have a tendency to deny
it
and reject it and similarly people
aren't practiced at seeing bad behavior
and stepping in as a third party or
receiving bad behavior and then
confronting it and saying that's not
okay don't do that to me don't do that
to other people so I think it's it's
difficult it's the the the
fight-or-flight mechanism the the
activation of the sympathetic nervous
system is that thing that tenses us up
and makes it hard to think clearly hard
to express ourselves clearly so this
event that I'm hoping to host at my
house and give some more guidance on is
the idea of kind of people brainstorming
what have been times in the past that
they've been brave what have been times
in the past where they wish they had
been brave and they weren't brave what
are times in the future where they
expect to have the opportunity to be
brave and that it'll really matter to
them and they want they don't know
they will be but they want to be brave
and then running through that simulation
where perhaps you're playing curious
scenario where you really want to be
brave
perhaps it's having a difficult
conversation with a housemate and I play
the housemate and I would like really
push at you and challenge you and not be
willing to hear it and sort of
deliberately try to activate your
fight-or-flight mechanism and then see
if you are able to stand stand strong be
brave and communicate what you need to
communicate in that moment in an
economist way not an aggressive and
violent yeah in a productive way that's
the last point that the fight or flight
mechanism like even if you're able to
have the conversation it might not go
the best way you could go worse yeah
yeah so so it's good that you're
inspiring the tough conversations
through inspiring people to fer bravery
and bravery to at least start the
process and then go through simulations
of what it would be like and work
through all the other wrinkles that are
gonna happen now it's also the
skillfulness of having the conversation
in a productive way exactly yeah this
actually all boils down to skillfulness
skillfulness and conversation
skillfulness and emotional and social
intelligence --is yeah and which are
very under taught in schools and I think
parents also focus a lot on just like
working and not taking care of their
kids we've kind of built a fabric where
that is the new norm yeah I think it's
adaptive its adaptive to let the big man
the alpha male get away with what he
gets away with like we in the me2 era
we're all kind of confused why do people
let him get along away with that for so
long
if you think back to the ancestral
environment the people that challenged
the alpha and didn't like his behavior
didn't pass on their genes you know this
is all evopsych stuff so it's it's a
hard to hard to quite say what's right
but it's that was a revelation to me to
notice like this is not a bug in human
behavior this is a feature this is
adaptive to put your head down and
ignore the abuses because it might come
to you if you don't but I think we are
pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah but I think we
live in a safer world now where that's
not the physical necessity but people
still have those behavioral patterns
there is a
evolutionary psychology answered to the
feature of why we don't address with the
issue at hand because we want our
genetics to move on we don't want a
challenge and then die because of
challenging but at the same time it's
both beautiful and very important that
there are now these challenges in the
safer environment that we've created
that challenges do exist that's great
but also challenges shouldn't happen for
the acceleration of Fame and these sort
of like manipulations of it and that
that that makes a big that makes people
feel like it you know takes away from
the importance of what's going on so
that's also another key point here that
it's like the the importance of what's
going on super important for the
instances that it's absolutely
critically like important the actual
like rapes and assaults and violence
that occur are horrible and are really
important to to have what's happening
happen and then there's the instances of
of like you know Mike Pence not being
able to take a meeting with a woman by
himself right now and I'm just like this
is stupid like the fact that this is
happening right now is stupid and we
have to figure out a way to make it so
that we can feel like we can be in the
same room as a person of the opposite
sex I think that's been his policy for
at least the last 15 or 20 years so I
don't think that's a recent thing but
yeah I have no idea I know nothing but
what I what I feel right now is I feel
like that it's that book that that the
other the other take on this is also
like hey like let's let's not like I
guess I I don't know enough about the
Azeez thing but you know just whatever
making making that such a such like a
yeah I think I think we're we're
definitely in a time of like correction
and I think with any correction there's
probably some element of over correction
yeah yeah that's good
the way the way I usually think about it
is that I I want to make sure that
behavior is corrected and if the
behavior if I if I personally feel
confident that the behavior is corrected
it doesn't feel necessary for me to like
I I personally look to escalate things
as far as are as is necessary to get an
apology here someone taking
responsibility for their action and
feeling confident they're gonna shift
their behavior but I think we do have an
overcorrection where there are some
scenarios where it's like something
inappropriate ten years ago there was an
apology and there's no reason to think
the behavior continues in my opinion
it's not appropriate to ruin someone's
career over that it's crazy I I think I
think in the in the Aziz case that's a
bit more complicated totally bland just
definitely there's definitely cases
where it even makes me yeah like feel
like what I'm doing I need to be careful
and that I think everyone needs to be
careful yeah everyone needs to be
careful but but I don't think we I don't
think like I guess propagating a fear
culture for from four men and it's not
it's not what it is but it sometimes
does feel that way yeah so but it's also
a fearful thing for women because there
are so many predatory type guys so like
yeah so there's it's very strange and
I'm really happy that you're impacting
all the gray area and the nuance as well
as the designs of how to be the [ __ ] you
or than know and how to get it into
festivals corporate clients events all
these different places you know that
that is it's really cool to be the black
sheep pushing that forward and we
appreciate that a lot and even being
able to talk about it today in such
great detail with somebody that has been
studying it for so much longer is
amazing and it's it's a new show you
know we haven't done before yeah just a
very brief circle back regarding the
fear question I know that is something
that a lot of men and a lot of leaders
are struggling with right now and I hope
that fear can be a motivator I hope they
can that can be a motivator for people
to
dig deep figure out like in what ways is
my behavior how I want it to be in what
ways is it in what ways do I need to
re-examine my behavior in what ways do I
look the other way when I see my buddy
not acting properly so I think it can be
a motivator for people to stand up and
be leaders in their own communities to
make sure that their behavior is
impeccable and that they are supporting
and enthusiastic consent culture so it's
it's an opportunity to focus the mind
yeah that's a good way to put it and to
teach really good habits and goals yeah
yeah so quick so couple quick questions
a little kind of rapid-fire through
these do you think we're alone in the
cosmos
oh yeah Fermi paradox is an interesting
one I don't think we're alone I think
there's some hard questions to answer
around why we haven't heard from others
there's um you've you've probably heard
of the dark forest explanation right was
it dark forest the dark forest so the
ones the ones that the one that I put
the highest probability on is just that
there tends to be a ceiling for
technological development where once
once that there's a narrow window
between when species can make enough
noise that they're heard over great
distances before they wipe themselves
out so there's just a couple hundred
year period but the other one the dark
forest ideas aren't actual general
intelligence or biowarfare news whatever
it is yeah yeah but the dark forest
scenario is that it's dangerous out
there to make noise so if you make noise
there might be consequences very quickly
that stopped you from making noise so if
there's if there is some other hostile
species Woking dark forest and cloaking
go hand in hand as well yeah you want to
cloak yourself right right so the
species species that are that are smart
are cloaking themselves and the ones
that are short-lived are making noise
yeah so or they're gonna kill themselves
like that existential the dark forest is
the it's a dangerous environment one and
then the other one I don't know if
there's a catchy name for the one if we
wipe ourselves out existential
extinction Frank stinks yeah I think
there are four extincted civilizations
than we can imagine yeah because it's
very difficult to figure out how these
thinking creatures figure out how to
work together yeah I think that we're
worse that we're still going we're still
about to go through them
in the next couple of decades yeah we'll
see if we even make it through well I
think a really important component of us
surviving the existential risks we have
emerging in the next couple hundred
years is emotional intelligence like I
think there are human problems that are
going to wipe us out that tribalism that
scarcity mindset that violence that
temper that inability to manage tough
emotions so that we have to externalize
it with violence rather than holding
those tough emotions and managing those
tough emotions inside so X versus ago is
something that I care a lot about and I
think that there's a lot of different
components to the solution a lot of
different components of the problem and
I think a good a strong component of it
is the human problem that we need to
need to figure out so yup yeah no good
good answer the the human centric
yeah theology and emotions not the only
solutions that support part do you think
we're in a simulation oh I mean I put a
reasonably high probability on it but
like so looking around at my life and
looking around at the people I know and
the amazing projects that I see
happening and like the people I get to
meet that almost kind of Rises raises my
estimation that we're in the simulation
because if you were creating a
simulation and then dropping your
intelligence into some random avatar
that doesn't know that it's in a
simulation like this is basically the
life you would drop it into right so
that's that's the that's the bit I
always find funny so oh yeah if we don't
wipe ourselves out I'm sure we'll do
ancestor simulations ah so excited for
the answer I think they'll give us the
insight into how this is not based
reality all right right yeah yeah it's
all the way down yeah yeah yep
and then last question is what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world
probably people coming together in
solving problems and making things
better and building building communities
and environments that delight them and
work for them so it's a good one hora
yeah okay it's like how do these ants on
this rock figure out how to work right
right yeah thank you so much for coming
on to our show thank you so much for
having me greatly appreciate it that's
great thank you I'm really happy that we
were able to talk through enthusiastic
consent culturally and this is uh you
know let's put a big flag in this
episode as like kind of like the first
public time that you know we haven't had
this on our show your first like
publicize yeah that's exciting stuff and
right now I was like thinking about all
those cool designs of diagrams of how to
like make this relatable and fun for
people so I'm excited to see your
iterations on okay well send you some
drafts and see what you think let's do
it let's do it
thanks everybody for tuning in if you
guys had a good time share it with two
other people go and talk to them about
enthusiastic in cell culture what that
means why it's important and these
relatable practices that we can do and
share with other people also subscribe
comment below join the community join
the familia go in comment let us know
your thoughts we'd love to hear from you
join us on patreon help us sustain and
grow this project impact more people
with it thank you very much to Ron our
producer and director much love everyone
thanks for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]